everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 4 of
our coverage at the 2019 u.s. chess
championship our competitors today
whites gonna be played by Jeffrey's
young we've covered a game from him
earlier in the tournament his opponents
ray Robson 24-year old he was the 2009
US Junior Champion at the time when he
was 14 and became the youngest
Grandmaster taking that title from
Nakamura no longer holds it but still
he's been one of the up-and-coming
youngsters in American chess so excited
to see these two competitors square off
starts out with pani for pani v 9 f3
knight c6 getting into the Rui Lopez
with Bishop to b5 and the knight to f6
Kass on the Kings side so this is the
Berlin defense seems like we saw this a
couple years ago in almost every single
game haven't seen it quite as often but
showing up here in the US Chess
Championship
so after pawn to d4 which is one of the
more common lines that we do see Knight
back to d6 pawn captures here and then
the knight takes on b5 so right away
black does have the bishop pair here
there's a couple ways that white can
continue to get back the material
decides to go ahead and first play pawn
a4 no real good square for the knight to
go to it is going to fall at some point
decides to come back here and then the
exchange in the center of the board
Queen to d4 pawn to d5 could take if you
wanted to decide to go and just bring
his Queen back here to d3 and then pawn
g6 getting ready to fianchetto on the
King side of the board bring the bishop
here to g7 catch on the Kings side if
Ray Robson would would like to 9 to see
three simple development move pawn to c6
solidifying the pawn chain on the Queen
side of the board Bishop to e3 just
getting that in the center of the board
here also attacking the pawn on a7 in
case this rook wants to move anywhere it
is attacking that pawn bishop coming to
f5 just getting it outside developed and
attacking the Queen right here so the
Queen does fall back to D 2 and then
Queen to a5 so Robson being pretty
aggressive on the board
right now rook t1 just centralizing both
sides just trying to figure out how they
are going to attack their opponent and
seeing as how the king is still here on
EI has not castled on either side of the
board decided to go ahead and bring his
rook over here start to attack and then
rape castles on the Queen sides it
doesn't have a ton of protection as far
as you know pawns in front so there
could be an attack that Geoffrey could
have here on the Queen side the board
but decided to go ahead and castle on
the Queen side and then pawn to e6 an
interesting move if you see how White is
going to continue here maybe Bishop to
d4 opening up the door for the rook to
now defend this pawn that seems like a
pretty decent option but pawn to e6
giving up this pawn and kind of have to
look at the board and say how is he
gonna get back that material or what
advantage is he going to get if he's
gonna give up a pawn and material so
pawn to e6 the Bishop's going to
recapture here Bishop to g5 attacking
the rook rook comes to d7 Bishop to f6
attacking the rook rook comes back to g8
Queen to e3 so just doubling up here
also attacking this pawn on a7 the Queen
currently is protecting it and then the
bishop comes down here to b4 so right
away it's not exactly clear how White's
gonna get back that material black
definitely has the advantage in my book
just from a material standpoint and I
don't see a clear attack then White has
decided to go and bring his rook to d1
so getting away from the double attack
on the e-file now maneuvers over here to
d1 Bishop to f5 so attacking this pawn
here on c2 and then a very interesting
move in the game and it's Knight to b5
now this move definitely looks tricky if
black takes here it opens up for a lot
of attacks that White has on this King
it's kind of out in the open here
there's now an isolated pawn the pawn
could take here on b5 opening up the
door to attack the Queen here if the
Queen moves then the Queen can come up
here take on a7 assuming that the Queen
moves here so lots of
that's that black cast to worry about
this is really that the best move black
would have a huge advantage if he
decides to go ahead and take here
because there's no real way to continue
the attack
maybe Queen comes back here Bishop to c5
attacking the Queen and whites threats
have stopped black can easily defend
this but in the game and just look too
tricky and so Rey Robson decides instead
to bring his bishop and come down
capture on C to do something didn't feel
right says you know Geoffrey's a nice
guy there's just no way he's gonna give
up his Knights here but if you're
Geoffrey you gotta try something you're
down that pawn him it's here almost feel
like he looked at this position said
okay I got a I got to be pretty
aggressive my opponent's castles on the
Queen side not a lot of protection as
far as pawns so even if I have to give
up material I need to try something so
it takes with his bishop here on c2 rook
to a c1 this also does open up there's a
simulant file that this rook can attack
here so after the bishop comes to f5 you
see the knight come up to a 7 this is
definitely different after the bishop
comes and takes this pawn on a c2 and
then the rook maneuvers here now it
would definitely be a bad move for the
pond to take because now we could just
see pawn take here attacking the Queen
if the Queen takes on b5 then just rook
here to see to check things are not
going to be good maybe rook to c7 Queen
over here to h3 check King to be eights
Bishop here to f5 pinning down the rook
things are not gonna go well for black
so had an opportunity to take the pot or
the night there on b5 but now that he
did not does not want to make that
mistake now so that brings the bishop
back here to f5 so the knight takes on
a7 check King over here to be eights
Knights to b5 King over here to aah
another one of those times where it
would be bad to take with the pawn here
after the pawn takes you could see a
huge threat now if the Queen moves you
know first we could see that the pawn
here Bishop to e5 but as soon as that
Queen
to move the Queen come up here to a7 but
in this position even here King to a7
Bishop comes down to d4 taking material
here things are just not going to go
well for black so correctly decides not
to take the night it is now a trap King
to a8 Bishop to c3 Bishop takes still
bad time to take with the pawn right
here Bishop comes back to b4 and takes
pawn down to d4 Queen d2 Queen up here
to a7 but you can see how bad this is
after pawn to b5 now this is pinning
down the Queen there's no way not for
black to lose this material so it's not
going to be good and you kind of get the
sense that Ray Robson is probably not
even looking at that at all anyway
decides yeah I'm not gonna take that
material so just not an option now if I
was gonna take it I would have taken it
earlier so after the bishop to c3 Bishop
takes we do see in exchange on the board
now an isolated pawn for whites on at
the C file not something that ripe
really white really wants their Bishop
to e6 work over here II won rook to e8
just trying to counter-attack into the
center of the board here pawn to h3
controlling this square on a g4 pun h5
serrate pushing on the King side the
board rook to e7 just doubling up on the
e-file Queen to c5 but it just has a
sense that White's just throwing as much
as he can a tray beret is just not
breaking it all still has a great pawn
structure here his King is pretty safe
because he has the Queen protecting him
there's just not enough material to
really continue to its hack here King 2b
eights Queen up here to a d6 check King
to c8 Queen down here c5 just no real
way to continue here King to d8 and then
pawn g3 just not doing too much me what
is white really going to try to do here
instead maybe c4 try to break up the
center so you know D file then you could
swing your rook over here to d1 an
attack that's an option but decides to
go ahead and play pawn to g3 then do too
much on the board in all reality
Pantanal takes on b5 the night has
finally fallen after the pawn captures
here the queen's own attack queen
sweetens back here to c7 pinning down
this pawn here on g3 not that this pawns
really gonna be going anywhere anytime
soon
but the Queen comes back here it's a d4
King to d7 rook up here to a4 and you
can see it's starting to slip away here
black has equal amount of pawns but he
does have the minor piece and that
bishops gonna be able to control most of
the board because it is an open board
state so rook over here to a c8 punt up
here to c4
Queen down here c5 says yeah I'll go
ahead and exchange material if you want
to so after the pawn takes Bishop
to f5 rook up here to e7 says yeah that
is that is great with me King to e5
check King b7 and then we see an
exchange on the board of the Queen's
that's exactly what ray is looking for
he has a huge advantage as far as the
material so try to get all the big
pieces off the board pretty much
eliminates all the threats that white
has so after pawn g4 King e 5 just
getting that involved into the game rook
down to f3 we do see an exchange in the
board and now Bishop to g4 attacking the
rook there's just not much more that's
Geoffrey can do here after rook to b8
controlling this pawn right here this
pawn is no longer going anywhere this
King can just go around and gobble up
and cereal in tandem with this
LightSquared bishop so in the end we do
have Jeffrey's young I had decided to
resign and Ray Robson gets the victory
so a lot of exciting matches so far in
the US chess tournament hopefully
everyone has been following along seeing
all the matches on it will you coverage
each day of a game that I find
particularly fascinating to cover but
hopefully you guys are Jory I hopefully
you're enjoying that the coverage that
I'm sharing and I thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys tomorrow for round
number 5